uh making money is not going to make you
happy
um what making money will do is it will
solve your money problems uh it will
remove a set of things that were in the
way of being happy
but it is not in of itself going to make
you happy i know
many unhappy very wealthy people
as i said before happiness comes from
peace but
and most of the time the person you have
to become to make money is a high
anxiety high stress high work
competitive person and when you have
been doing that for 20 30 40 50 years
and then you suddenly make money you
can't turn that off you've trained
yourself you've conditioned yourself in
such a way that you are now just a high
anxiety person so now you have to learn
how to be happy and uh you know how to
be happy is a much more complex much
deeper topic which i hope to get into at
some point but uh i i would say that it
starts with one very simple thing which
is you truly have to believe that
happiness is a choice you make and it's
a skill that you develop it is not
necessarily an intrinsic quality you
aren't stuck where you started
it's not a static thing everyone has a
different body but everyone can almost
everybody can be fit if they work hard
enough at it so the same way everyone
has a different mind and starts a
different dna in the mind
in the brain but if you work at it you
can become a lower stress lower anxiety
person i would say that you know if you
checked in on me 10 years ago
i would have been and if you'd asked me
how happy i was i would have dismissed
the question
i didn't like to talk about it but i
would have said i'm like a two out of
four or three out of four or a three
sorry two out of ten or three out of ten
or maybe even a four out of ten of my
best days but i did not value being
happy today i went nine out of ten and
yes having money helps but it's actually
a very small piece of it most of it is
just i've learned over the years that my
own happiness is the most important
thing to me i've cultivated it through a
series of techniques
i have lowered my identity i have
lowered the chattering of my mind i
don't care that much about things that
don't really matter
i don't get involved in politics i don't
hang around unhappy people
i really value my time in this earth
i read philosophy i meditate i hang
around with happy people
and it works you can very slowly but
steadily and methodically improve your
happiness baseline just like you can
improve your fitness just like you can
improve your intellect by reading so all
of that is absolutely possible but it
first begins with just believing that
it's possible
if you look at medicine
there's something in medicine called the
placebo effect and that is basically if
i take a medicine and it's not real it's
a sugar pill like homeopathy
if i believe that it's real it actually
has a chance of working for a certain
class of ailments if i have a headache
and i take a pill that i think will cure
my headache even if that pill turns out
not to be real or have anything in it
there's a reasonable chance it will just
cure my headache through the placebo
effect because i believe it was real
but
the placebo effect in fact is not
something you should fall into easily
because if i have cancer and somebody
gives me a placebo cancer pill and i
take it thinking it's going to work it's
probably not going to work the placebo
effect is not that powerful especially
for
physical
things of the body
and i might die because i'm too busy
doing placebo effect medicines when and
when really i need chemotherapy
or something
more extreme a more extreme intervention
but
when it comes to placebo effects of the
mind
it's actually really good to believe
because placebo effects of the mind
there's very few downside consequences
if someone says to me hey meditation
will make me make you happier i should
go in with a positive mindset because
i control my own entire internal world
and whatever i believe to be true
is very likely to be true there's very
little physics to override like there
might be with the physical body
so when it comes to placebo effects of
the mind you should always go and
positively incline so the first step to
being happier is just to believe that
you can be happier and that it's your
choice and it's a skill that you can
develop just like any other skill so
that's it i'm going to leave it on that
thank you all very much and i hope to
see you all on twitter and periscope
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you